[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend ihnen
allen champions league mittwoch und den
hat katja hat striesow später blick ja
auch die champions league dienstag
schönen guten abend und hier die themen
die wir für sie vorbereitet haben
leid und zerstörung nach dem rückzug
große gruppen um kiew wird das ganze
zerstörerische ausmaß des krieges
sichtbar
kehrtwende des gesundheitsministers
corona infizierte müssen sich nun doch
weiter isolieren die opposition ist
sauer lauterbach sagt der fehler lag bei
mir
mehr tempo bei den erneuerbaren
bundeswirtschaftsminister weg will mit
einem gesetzespaket sonne und
windenergie massiv ausbauen
viele fürchten jahr das boot
stellvertretend für die entsetzliche und
brutale dimension russische angriffe im
großraum kiew steht jetzt nachdem
moskaus truppen die region verließen
zeigt sich der schrecken auch in
borodjanka und 40 kilometer nordwestlich
der hauptstadt über die zerstörung und
verzweiflung dort berichten tobias
häfner und volker dutschek
ein fotoalbum schulabschluss klasse 1991
dimitrios kopf hat es in den trümmern
eines wohnblocks in der kleinstadt
borodjanka entdeckt
wir suchen nach persönlichen
gegenständen viel haben wir noch nicht
gefunden aber immerhin diese bilder aus
dem besitz meiner mutter
eine fast unmögliche aufgabe für den
25-jährigen und viele andere die
trümmerberge tonnen schwer und meter
hoch und was noch in den himmel ragt ist
oft einsturzgefährdet dazwischen kleine
momente des glücks wenn altbekannte
gesichter wieder auftauchen überlebt
haben
brody anker liegt 80 kilometer
nordwestlich von kiew war wochenlang von
russischen truppen besetzt nun sind die
russen verschwunden aus dieser
gespenstische szenerie die wenig
hoffnung gibt die größten ängste der
zurückkehrenden vermisste niemals finden
dafür viele andere tote opfer russischer
grollt hatten
zu anfang des krieges haben sie menschen
auf der straße und den autos einfach
getötet die leichen lagen und saßen dann
da mindestens zwei wochen lang schwer
sie weg gebracht hat keine ahnung
man erzählt sich im ort auch von folter
von vergewaltigungen tschetschenische
kämpfer seien involviert gewesen was
davon in welchem umfang stimmt soll nun
ermittelt werden die ukrainische justiz
vermutet weiterhin dass die verbrechen
in borodjanka noch schlimmer gewesen
sein könnten als im 25 kilometer
entfernten butscher dem ort der die welt
gerade erschüttert hat experten sehen
eine mögliche strategie russlands und
dann zählt das einerseits auf die
ukraine also eine art psychologische
kriegsführung um die zivilbevölkerung
und die ukrainischen streitkräfte zu
demoralisieren sie einzuschüchtern und
zu zermürben es geht aber auch auf den
westen also auf uns und da geht es darum
die öffentlichkeit zu spalten zweifel zu
säen und möglicherweise zu verhindern
dass die westlichen staaten gemeinsam
und entschlossen eingreifen womit die
welt somit dort noch konfrontiert werden
wird wo die kämpfe andauern völlig offen
in kiew ist katrin eigendorf und war
heute schon zum drehen in borodjanka
kathrin was hast du erlebt
die situation im bauma janka ist noch
wesentlich schlimmer was das ausmaß der
zerstörungen angeht als in butscher man
muss sich vorstellen große teile der
innenstadt sind komplett zerstört
dort wurden wurde von der russischen
armee in wohnblocks hineingeschossen die
häuser sie werden wahrscheinlich bald
einstürzen die menschen irren dort herum
suchen ihre sachen zusammen versuchen
das noch rauszuholen was sie retten
können viele menschen wirken dort völlig
verzweifelt manche auch traumatisiert
und sie erzählen ähnliche geschichten
wie die menschen uns in butter erzählt
haben russische soldaten müssen durch
das durch den ort gefahren sein haben
einfach wild um sich geschossen in
fenster von menschen hinein die menschen
haben gesagt dass sie sich teilweise
tagelang nicht aus den häusern getraut
haben
es gibt einige berichte von einwohnern
dass die haben übereinstimmend gesagt
dass sie auch tschetschenen erlebt haben
die besonders brutal vor sich gegangen
sind die mit schwarzen masken in der
stadt waren waffen auf menschen
gerichtet haben das sind die berichte
der einwohner das muss man natürlich
alles mit entsprechender vorsicht
genießen denn die menschen wie gesagt
sind traumatisiert
teilweise sitzen sie wirklich
fassungslos da in den trümmern ihrer
häuser man wird diese berichte
abgleichen und untersuchen müssen
in dem ort ist das große problem dass
vermutlich noch sehr sehr viele tote
menschen aus den häusern die dort
bombardiert werden geborgen werden und
man hat auch gemerkt wie überfordert
eigentlich die ukrainische regierung mit
dieser situation ist wir haben erlebt
wie die menschen dort mit bloßen händen
helfer die steine abgetragen haben weil
nicht einmal das technische gerät dort
zur verfügung stand geschweige denn dass
irgendjemand da in der lage ist sich um
die traumatisierten einwohner zu kümmern
danke für die schilderungen nach kiew
katrin eigendorf
die bundesregierung will sich zum
weiteren vorgehen im ukraine krieg ja
eng mit den nato partnern abstimmen
heute in brüssel das
außenministertreffen des
verteidigungsbündnisses und vieles
deutet bei den waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine auf einen strategiewechsel hin
man spricht dabei nicht mehr nur über
verteidigungswaffen dazu grüner krüger
mehr soldaten an der ostflanke wie hier
im manöver in litauen die nato ist sich
einig über ihre eigene marschrichtung
über das neue strategische konzept
uneins ist sie sich bei der waffen hilfe
für die ukraine tschechien liefert nun
panzer und sieht wohl nur selbst darin
keine abkehr von der linie
ausschließlich waffen zur verteidigung
zu schicken
ich würde den begriff angriffswaffen
nicht verwenden die waffen dienen der
verteidigung der ukrainischen
souveränität
nachahmung also empfohlen da gehen die
meinungen auseinander
ich glaube dass jedes einzelne land eine
entscheidung trifft und
das glaube ich dass wir hier
die frage im rahmen der nato nicht
hinbekommen und dass da eine
koordination stattfinden ich denke jedes
land muss alles tun was es kann tut
deutschland alles was es kann
das müssen sie einen deutschen minister
fragen die deutsche ministerin sagte
heute nichts doch der druck wächst mit
jedem neuen indiz für russische
kriegsverbrechen damit tritt dieser
krieg in den augen vieler bündnispartner
in eine neue phase auf die es neue
antworten brauche schwere waffen für die
ukraine und ein stoppschild für jeden
dialog mit russland die neue strategie
werde die neue lage spiegeln so der
größte nato partner bei der ankunft wenn
russland in dem strategischen konzept
noch ein gesprächspartner ist dann wohl
nur ohne putin
der krieg die sanktionen gegen russland
und die deutschen waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine um all das ging es heute im
parlament
es muss unser ziel bleiben dass russland
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt das waren die
vielleicht deutlichsten worte von olaf
scholz bei der heutigen kanzler
befragung und der sich anschließenden
bundestagsdebatte mehr von david gap hat
liegen um aufzurütteln
sie gedenken den opfern ausputzer den
getöteten ukraine in ihrem heimatland
eine aktion vor dem berliner reichstag
um druck zu machen auf die da drinnen
mehr zu tun kanzler scholz zuvor bei der
regierungsbefragung hatte seine
bestürzen ausgedrückt die entsetzlichen
bilder ausputzer haben uns alle tief
erschüttert
russische soldaten haben dort vor ihrem
rückzug ein massaker an ukrainischen
zivilisten verübt darunter kinder frauen
und alte menschen es muss unser ziel
bleiben dass russland diesen krieg nicht
gewinnt der druck auf russland solle
erhöht werden auch durch weitere
waffenlieferungen
doch gerade bei diesem thema steht die
regierung massiv und der kritik schlecht
kommuniziert zu spät zu wenig die union
fordert gepanzerte waffen gegebenenfalls
kampf panzer und artilleriegeschosse für
die ukraine die brauchen sie nun mal um
bestehen zu können
und da muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn ihre antwort heute hier ist ja da
sollte deutschland nicht vorpreschen da
sollten wir nicht die ersten sein die
das machen dann ist das aus meiner sicht
eine unzureichende antwort die
verteidigungsministerin widerspricht dem
vorwurf lieferungen auch schwerer waffen
würden zu zögerlich genehmigt unnötig
bürokratisch gebremst das ist kein keine
bürokratische hürde in diesem
zusammenhang ist eines ganz wichtig die
nato und deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur kriegspartei zu
werden in enger abstimmung mit den eu
und nato partnern sollen weitere waffen
geliefert werden und der druck auf
russland über neue sanktionen erhöht
dazu gehören einfuhrverbote für kohle
dazu gehören transaktions verbote gegen
wichtige weitere russische banken ein
weiteres einfrieren von vermögenswerten
warum schafft es belgien
vermögenswerte russische oligarchen in
höhe von zehn milliarden euro
einzufrieren warum schafft es frankreich
850 millionen einzufrieren italien hat
mehrere hundert millionen euro
beschlagnahmen und deutschland liegt bei
95 millionen das doch unfassbar
die gräueltaten von butscher wird nach
auch im deutschen bundestag und erhöhen
den druck auf die regierung weiter zu
handeln
wir sind jetzt bei caron da gibt es eine
faustdicke überraschung
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
innerhalb kürzester zeit eine 180 grad
wende bei der isolations pflicht
entscheidung hingelegt und fehler
eingeräumt gestern mittag noch hatte
lauterbach die entscheidung verteidigt
dass die isolationsschicht für positiv
getestete bald entfallen sollte knapp
neun stunden später in der aufzeichnung
der zdf sendung markus lanz kündigte er
an die regel bleiben heike slansky über
diese verblüffende kehrtwende
kaum erst verkündet und schon wieder
einkassiert wer corona hat sollte ab mai
selbst entscheiden ob er zu hause bleibt
oder nicht so lauterbach am montag
gestern abend dann bei markus lanz die
rolle rückwärts
ich glaube dass das zwar den
gesundheitsämtern helfen würde das der
symbolische schaden aber ist nicht mehr
so gefährlich so verheerend ist dass man
diese isolations ordnung so nicht machen
kann nach heftiger kritik ruder der
minister zurück auf twitter nachts um
halb drei hier habe ich einen fehler
gemacht unmut in den eigenen reihen
himmel von der opposition an einem tag
die eine sache sagen die haben nächsten
tag wieder revidiert also das ist ein
stil der sehr sehr schlecht ist insofern
bitte ich auch da im sinne der
kolleginnen kollegen aus der koalition
um entschuldigung das ist kein gutes
kommunizieren auch die bundesländer
zitiert wenn man das einfach per ordre
de mufti talk show verkündet lässt das
ja die länder im regen stehen und
verunsichert die bevölkerung und das ist
schon eine kommunikative fehlleistung
wenn man sieht dass die also vorschläge
nicht wirklich also funktionieren muss
man sie zurücknehmen und muss nicht stur
beim vorschlag bleiben obwohl man selbst
nicht mehr überzeugt ist lauterbach in
erklärungsnot morgen die abstimmung zur
impfpflicht für die er eindringlich
geworben hatte ausgang offen
da wollen wir doch noch mal nachfragen
chuck unterlag energy in berlin da haben
sich tatsächlich viele die augen
gerieben wie ist dieser überraschende
lauterbach schritt einzuschätzen das
fragen sich tatsächlich viele hier in
berlin man hat fast den eindruck als
würde der bundesgesundheitsminister dann
noch mit seinem rollenwechsel ein wenig
hadern er ist ja im vergangenen jahr als
der große pandemie erklärer mit viel
fachwissen bekannt geworden bevor er zum
minister wurde und jetzt ist er aber
pandemie manager und da zählt war das
fachwissen natürlich auch noch aber er
muss eben vor allem beschlüsse
koordinieren eng mit den ländern
abstimmen und dann in dieser abstimmung
auch umsetzen das ist hier
offensichtlich nicht passiert dieser
alleingang dann auch noch vorgetragen im
fernsehen hat viele verstimmt wir haben
heute auch noch mal nachgefragt der
vorsitzende der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
was sie von der ganzen sache hält sie
hat uns dazu schriftlich mitgeteilt die
entscheidung die vorschläge noch einmal
zu ändern konnte bislang noch nicht mit
den ländern abgestimmt werden und wir
erwarten dass wir uns zeitnah
austauschen werden also das heißt mit
anderen worten auch da muss noch etwas
kommen und die kommunikation muss sich
deutlich verbessern
das ganze kommt zu einem zeitpunkt wo
gute kommunikation auch wirklich gefragt
ist denn wenn morgen der bundestag sich
nicht auf eine impfpflicht einigen
sollte für die karl lauterbach ja immer
eingetreten ist dann wird er schauen
müssen wie ihr die impfquote bis zum
herbst noch erhöhen kann und auch das
geht wieder nur in enger zusammenarbeit
mit den ländern da ist eben gute
kommunikation gute überzeugungsarbeit
gefragt und beides hat er heute nicht
gezeigt danke für diese einschätzung
schack und ella nach berlin mehr auf
erneuerbare energien setzen dieses ziel
der ampel regierung erfährt durch den
krieg noch mehr dringlichkeit heute hat
das kabinett das reformpaket von
wirtschaftsminister habeck auf den weg
gebracht so sollen zb
genehmigungsverfahren vereinfacht werden
kommunen finanziell von wind oder solar
parks profitieren und neue solaranlagen
rentabler werden ziel ist ab 2035 nahezu
den kompletten strom aus erneuerbarer
energie zu beziehen britta buchholz
solche dächer soll es nicht mehr geben
stattdessen sollen sie mit photovoltaik
voll belegt sein das ist das ziel
problem bisher bürokratie und gesetze
allein der bau eines windrads dauert
durchschnittlich sechs jahre das
sogenannte oster paket beschreibt auf
fast 600 seiten wie es drastisch
schneller gehen soll dafür werden viele
gesetze geändert
wir werden erleben dass wir in dieses
paket passiert wir nicht mehr gesetzlich
oder im ordnungsrahmen die probleme
haben sondern in der produktion in den
bautätigkeiten
das ziel ist ambitioniert in 13 jahren
soll strom fast ausschließlich aus
erneuerbaren quellen kommen aktuell
liegt deutschland bei gut 40 prozent
die hürden dafür sind unglaublich hoch
denn im paket fehlen auch ein paar
wichtige und zentrale einigung mit den
bundesländern am ende wird es darauf
ankommen dass die länder und die
kommunen vor ort die flächen finden die
am besten geeignet sind für erneuerbare
energien neu auf zwei prozent der
landesfläche sollen sich verpflichtend
windräder drehen die energiewende manche
lehnen sie rigoros ab eine
energieversorgung ohne fossile
energieträger und ohne kernenergie
völlig illusorisch das schlimme daran
ist hunderttausende von arbeitsplätzen
stehe auf dem spiel weil die industrie
das nicht annäherungsweise abrufen kann
das kabinett billigte das energiepaket
die fdp hat zwar formal zugestimmt
möchte aber noch einmal diskutieren der
wirtschaftsminister gab sich gelassen
differenzen für leicht lösbar
der kampf gegen den rechtsextremismus
werde ihre wichtigste aufgabe sein so
nancy faeser am tag als ihren amtseid
als neuer bundesinnenministerium ablegte
eine großrazzia heute in der neonazi
szene scheint sie zu bestätigen in
insgesamt elf bundesländern gegen die
bundesanwaltschaft gegen militante
rechtsextreme netzwerke vor im fokus
eine kampfsport gruppe in thüringen saar
attacke
er soll der anführer des neonazi
netzwerks sein der 24 jährige leon er
aus eisenach in thüringen schießen üben
in tschechien so präsentiert er sich im
internet auf instagram
heute nun werden leon er und drei
weitere tatverdächtige festgenommen und
dem ermittlungsrichter am
bundesgerichtshof in karlsruhe
vorgeführt vorwurf mitgliedschaft in
einer rechtsextremistischen kriminellen
vereinigung ziel dieser kampfsport
gruppe und ziel auch von e on air ist
nach unserer erkenntnis die schaffung
eines nazi kiezes in eisenach und auch
der kampf und die körperliche
auseinandersetzung mit linken gegnern
und vertretern der polizei und der
staatlichen behörden heute morgen in
eisenach polizisten tragen diesen
granaten ähnlichen gegenstand aus einer
kneipe die kneipe sol león er gehören
außerdem sollen hier kanister mit
chemikalien und dokumente gesichert
worden
insgesamt durchsuchten heute zeitgleich
800 polizisten objekte in elf
bundesländern etwa 50 rechtsextremisten
zählen die ermittler zum neuen neonazi
netzwerk einige von ihnen sollen bereits
der verbotenen nazi organisation combat
18 angehört haben uns ist heute ein sehr
harter schlag gegen rechtsextremistische
und rechts terroristische strukturen in
deutschland gelungen es ist deshalb so
wichtig was heute passiert ist weil wir
auf gezeigt haben dass der rechtsstaat
sehr wehrhaft ist die weiteren
ermittlungen werden jetzt zeigen wie
groß und wie gefährlich das neue neonazi
netzwerk ist
so schnitt wir sind beim sport und bei
der fußball champions league hat ja
heute abend spielen die bayern ihr
viertelfinal-hinspiel jürgen klopp und
sein fc liverpool sind da schon einen
kleinen schritt weiter denn sie spielten
und gewannen bereits gestern abend 3 zu
1 bei benfica lissabon
jürgen klopp strahlt seine spieler
glänzen der fc liverpool souverän in
lissabon die reds diesmal in gelb
bereits nach 17 minuten in führung
gebracht hatte der ehemalige leipziger
mit dem ersten tor weitere 17 minuten
später leitet alexander arnold auf luis
diaz mané verwandelt zu 20 nach dem
seitenwechsel missling konaté der
abwehrversuch darwin verkürzt auf 1 2
doch in der 87 minute stellt luis diaz
den alten zwei-tore-abstand wieder her
schaafheim und das war erst das hinspiel
mehr nicht wir sind jedenfalls
vorbereitet
beste aussichten für kommende woche vor
dem rückspiel in liverpool
und auch manchester city ist weiter im
königsklassen soll allerdings war es ein
zähes stück arbeit für das team von pep
guardiola das 1 0 gegen atletico madrid
der durchaus
verhaltensauffällige torjubel von
mancitys coach pep guardiola verrät die
enorme anspannung in einem match in dem
kevin de bruyne für die sky blues nach
70 minuten der einzige treffer gelingt
die tatsächlich beste chance von
atlético madrid lässt klare schlüsse zu
auf die von trainer simone verordnete
spanische mauertaktik im rückspiel in
madrid so viel scheint sicher dürfte es
nach dem knappen 1 0 der citizens wieder
ähnlich emotional zugehen
und diese vier spieler heute abend
ausführlich also auch dass der bayern in
sportstudio champions league 23 uhr
geht's los dann fehlen dann katja wir
schauen fix auf die mittwochs lotto
zahlen und die gehen so 2 19 22 24
29 31 superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen
auf otto.de und auf der zdf textseite
morgen zieht ein sturmtief auf das
bedeutet viel wind viel regen mehr dazu
gleich von katja horneffer
gesundheitsminister lauterbach im
heute-journal interview ab 21.45 mit
christian sievers vom gesamten heute 19
team herzlichen dank für das interesse
einen entspannten abend und gerne bis
morgen
[Musik]
sturmtief emma 7 ist heute vom atlantik
schon weiter in richtung osten gezogen
hat jetzt langsam schottland erreichen
und zieht morgen weiter in richtung süd
schweden es bringt viel wind und viel
regen mit und das merken wir schon heute
nacht da überdeckt der regen schon fast
ganz deutschland nur im äußersten osten
bleibt es noch trocken das wird eine
wilde nacht mit tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 10 und 5 grad und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen ähnlich wie heute
meist zwischen 8 und 17 grad und morgen
regnet es kräftig eben nordwesten
lockern die wolken auch mal auf und dann
entwickeln sich kräftige schauer zum
teil auch gewitter dazu pfeift dieser
starker bis stürmischer südwestwind der
höhepunkt des sturms den erwarten wir
wohl für morgen mittag dann sind
wirklich schwere sturmböen hier im
thüringer wald oder im harz zu erwarten
orkanartige sturmböen und orkanböen
beschränken sich aber wohl auf die
nordsee und die vogesen am freitag ist
er nicht mehr der wind das große problem
sondern der intensive dauerregen im
südwesten am samstag wird das markant
kälter der sonntag wird dann schon
wieder freundlicher guten abend